a high-heeled hiker news oh no that
sounds like a nightmare submitted by
quack-quack-quack
holy moly I don't even know what that's
what he's saying what is that
that one hip-hop rap song I don't know
what what what it's not yeah yeah yeah I
think I made that up in my head
I don't know cuz the Mexican restaurant
do do do do do do do do you yeah it's
not guac okay oh come on come on
teenager a climbed the highest mountain
in Britain wearing a five-inch heel
what's the highest mountain in Britain
like [ __ ] nottingham hill or some
[ __ ] wait in five-inch [ __ ]
heels
oh those are [ __ ] calves none of you
arches all haha not impressed you should
be have you ever tried hi girls
no that's what I'm not a person you
should try them and you might be
impressed high heels
I've got close to pivot II think that's
a nice that sneakers out there we're
good about the clear stripper kind or
are we talking about the pump but we're
not talking about the [ __ ] sneaker
people right we're talking about the
high heel person I know but like Wayne
calling it now if you're walking in
heels in nature is it the soft soil
going to make the back part of the
stiletto heel be like dig deep inside
there's a walk in Sacramento for like
sexual assault and stuff like that where
all the guys will do like a 3k in heels
like walk in her shoes
so it's like guys that's a cool idea
like I got it but it's all the guys
throwing heels in the wok of 3k for
charity yeah but it's cool idea that
actually make media but like hey you're
gonna beat up some [ __ ] negative no
the pain to go through what it's all
white leaders that the walking on its
regular folk
you know it's regular folk but I'm just
saying that theme of it they give them
periods and stuff there so what they
punch them in the [ __ ] [ __ ] so
they're [ __ ] but we loved kidding
everyone's are you serious
nor child's a little more hardcore than
SoCal
no we're chill up there big trucks
wakeboards Oh a Sacramento yes a little
bit different so this a student this art
student from London but also art student
so I expected he was tasked to make
something passionate about something
that they are passionate about in order
to apply for this particular scholarship
so the 19 year old his name has been and
so he went to Scotland to hike up the
tallest mountain of the Heather and it
goes all the way up about 4,400 feet
absolutely level smart man
so he Panna he has been hiking for like
about 13 years
so hold of he was five this is what it
looked like when he was hiking so he
decided to combine holy [ __ ] fashion
which is hiking and drag culture bondage
is pretty big its day think that's
pretty big he's cheating he's got the
ski yeah yeah yeah he's cheating
honestly honestly it is because he's
distributing his weight into another
place oh just your foot being in this
position for a long at time it's a rule
I just imagine like your toes because
those shoes are like padded like toes
gimmick but it does take away from it
Teeter that's all I'm saying
I'm still giving it to him do you think
he looked fierce while walking or do you
think he looked like he was falling all
over the plane I can show you I think of
the wobbler he's passionate about the
drag community then he's fish hi
here's Rick let's these action waffle
yes at all well here's what's on Drock
so smart he was with spanning 40 to 50
miles an hour when so it was like really
really windy and anything that was
non-stop raining when he was there so
like even like a British hurricane in
shoes I am calm that was fighting
Braveheart while he's walking up there
yeah you've been on his way up there one
of the straps broke on his heels we had
to tape the shoe to his foot
why does he have backups he's
Argentinean better prepare yeah they're
Louis Vuitton they didn't want to bring
I know he said like he went up with a
couple of friends and so they were
selling him for this a project of his
and they only made it a little bit more
than halfway up and that's when he
decided to turn back around because the
rain got too dangerous for them to keep
going and so on the way down he did if I
can shoot them it was just on the way up
that he wore the fireman children took
five hours I feel like if I was a
mountain goat watching this I was
purposely [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
might look at this stupid as you Medrano
[ __ ] hike this thing and heels
CERN is ranadev how do we have miles
like how many miles you okay Mountain
Goats don't [ __ ] around though they got
those little ass feet make a climb like
anywhere they're like on as little as
rock looking at rock climbers like hey
[ __ ] and I got the [ __ ] princes Lea
[ __ ] horns I know he hiked up almost
3,000 feet oh here we go
that's almost mile hyah how come mom
goats aren't afraid of heights I think
we do fit it's not there holy [ __ ] great
god damn even 300 have a heart of [ __ ]
dude
coughing great race 90 very worn down
she knows great dress Oh never wanted
you all right ah homie it was Michael
Jackson oh yeah this gorgeous
yeah they never go back yeah he killed
it for being its first time too yeah
those do seem pretty high yeah I don't
think I ever want to wear heels on the
mountains because it's like wearing ice
skates in the desert I'm not going about
like the Sahara where you couldn't maybe
kind of ski down I'm talking about the
Mojave Ryan it's already hard with
regular shoes yeah how you made an extra
harder with those heels man yeah well it
was part of his project did he win I'm
not sure oh he better he's bleeding [ __ ]
that's our boy though no he also created
a go fund me page to raise money for
LGBT rights and also to provide footwear
for barefoot children around the world
that's cool
that's what Tom's does do right like for
every pair you buy they donate a pair
Tom's is horseshit man really yeah
what's wrong with toms what host you
told us I don't know my god like 50 60
bucks they just watch Argentina and I
forgot what they're called but there's
some shoe in Argentina and there went
three bucks and he literally just took
that made his own put the Argentine flag
on it and sold it for a million dollars
I'm here to dumb white folks my head
it's the Argentine flag that's what
Tom's is but the logo yes the blue white
and blue one oh you're flying out like a
golden oh yeah so it's the colors it's
just kung fu shoes in a burlap sack
that's what it is in there literally
there's like what everybody works down
there like three bucks okay Cooper that
[ __ ] is just there to be sure yeah kung
fu in a burlap sack yeah that's all this
I think the point is is that every pair
you buy supposed to go to say his bank
account yeah that too [ __ ] you Tom I you
know what I found out about these
charities that [ __ ] up economies of
these like four countries like they'll
come in and then they'll flood the
market with all these free shoes so all
the shoe stores and all the hew makers
in that poor country loser like
businesses and jobs so there's no
industry in that country anymore I
doesn't yo [ __ ] you Tom so nobody has
jobs man just kidding tom you've got a
teacher man of fish true [ __ ] joke
yes Tom Tom Tom
teacher-man fish you know what though I
give mad props to is a stunt women and
heels like when they're doing karate or
anything like a James Bond [ __ ] or
something yes what the [ __ ] dude how'd
you even do them or even like artists
performing a concert like please nada
especially like super high here when
like how does she not break though why
are high heels a thing but it does make
like a chick's legs look good yeah
that's the caller does it make the butt
stick out two per minute and squash it
just it just looks super elegant
it makes her legs look longer and it
makes the girl looks tall like that give
you a good pocket doesn't automatically
flexes your legs so it looks good I
guess okay one is just like a better
like well cuz that's because they need
to get better Layton where he'll look
even more better so then why don't guys
were on one night like Napoleon is the
one and the French to job yeah men
invented you men you have to wear under
them French you storm what am i history
class
princess this is great you know those
leprechaun shoes with the [ __ ] belt
buckle on the front yeah yeah
probably our heel cowboy boots are kind
of healed camps my chemo came into the
[ __ ] picture and then guys wanted me
then what are you man their own idea
whether it has to be I was at the LV
store and they have some secret you know
what
Elvina or Italian Vuitton store sorry
brother I'm okay I can't go that sir I
didn't I was just looking and there's
these sneaky-ass shoes and I thought was
pretty tight similar Sodom I almost
bought up their heels except there are
700 other [ __ ] that but the shoe on the
outside looks like a regular sneaker but
inside there's like this much list
that's what I mean just the heel the
whole thing I was wearing I was her hi
I'm like oh that's what I need which is
outsider that's I go like they have
litters I think they even bought any
inside 6 but these look like actual they
look stupid
no no but I think you just buy some and
shove it inside your converse really ah
I think the way that I feel um like I
think any other normal shoe because it
doesn't accommodate for that cushion
it's gonna yeah you're gonna have to
ankle like hell out of the shoe I didn't
is what it's made to look like it's
gonna fit know what adds height for guys
work boots oh yeah a lot of [ __ ] inch
stomp the yard bro he loved his military
boots hell yeah all of a sudden I fix
Tito stomp around some Timbo and heavy
can't really kick anybody with that I
had a stuntwoman French let me try on
her heels because she was like wait all
at me I was like for keeping that [ __ ] I
was broke my ankle it's a hard to [ __ ]
you have the same size I didn't try
doing a round kick and my other ankle
just twisted oh yeah you don't have been
stabilizing muscles yeah I don't have
the same muscle those crazy I don't have
they do it hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discuss just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video it's right up
[Music]